ist das geheimnis endlich gelüftet was
steckt hinter dem monströsen
seeungeheuer das angeblich im
schottischen loch ness leben sollen
immer wieder gibt es erzählungen in
denen das monster auftaucht manche gehen
sogar von einem überlebenden dinosaurier
aus fachleute aus neuseeland wollen das
mysteriöse monster jetzt endlich
gefunden haben gibt es ist also doch
klingt zum science fiction lebens
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktive team
locken und dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen und vielen
dank für den spannenden themen vorschlag
der aus unserer kohlen telegramm
community kam der link dazu ist in der
video beschreibung dort bekommt ihr die
videos täglich werbefrei vor allen
anderen
ihr könnt mit diskutieren und
themenvorschläge machen schon seit mehr
als 1500 jahren kursieren erzählungen
über das monster von loch ness das erste
mal sollen es im jahr 564 in dem
schottischen süßwassersee gesichtet
worden sein und einen mann attackiert
haben doch der hatte wohl glück und
überlebte den angriff den erzählungen
nach nur durch die hilfe gottes fest
steht noch nest ist etwa 230 meter tief
und sehr dunkel und es gibt einen
regelrechten nessie tourismus noch nen
es ist wohl der bekannteste aller
schottischen sehen denn gerüchte gab es
schon immer viele und vor allem dieses
bild heizte die debatte um nessie
kräftig an ist dort etwa ein langer als
mit einem kleinen kopf zu sehen der da
aus dem wasser ragt und entfernt an
einen dinosaurier erinnert das bild
stellte sich im nachhinein als fälschung
heraus doch die gerüchteküche kochte
weiter
doch damit könnte jetzt schluss sein ein
forschungsteam aus neuseeland hat
nämlich im vergangenen jahr 250
wasserproben aus loch ness genommen und
diese auf dna stückchen untersucht mehr
als 500 millionen erbgut sequenzen
wurden analysiert und mit bereits
bekannten sequenzen aus bestehenden
datenbanken abgeglichen
dabei nutzen die forschenden die
tatsache dass jedes lebewesen ständig
sein erbgut in der umwelt verteilt
menschen tiere und höchstwahrscheinlich
auch seeungeheuer verlieren nicht nur
schuppen haare oder federn sondern auch
urin speichel oder andere ausscheidungen
fachleute können solche rest sind sogar
immer noch nach
weisen wenn die haare oder schuppen
schon längst im seewasser zerfallen und
verschwunden sind sehr gute analyse
methoden machen das möglich mit hilfe
von computern kann dann festgestellt
werden zu welchem lebewesen die
gefundene dna am ehesten gehört dazu der
biologe nil gemmel der an der studie
beteiligt war
das ist der vorteil der umwelt dna sie
ist ein extrem leistungsstarkes und
robustes werkzeug um alle lebenden wesen
sowohl groß als auch mikroskopisch klein
in einer umgebung zu dokumentieren wenn
also ein seemonster in loch ness lebt
dann müsste man auch die dna von ihm
aufspüren können und das ergebnis könnte
monsterjäger aus alten zeiten recht
geben wort tatsächlich bereits im jahr
1933 hatte ein forschungsteam spekuliert
dass es sich bei dem monster wohl um
einen riesigen handeln könnte taucht
teams hatten damals von aden berichten
die dick wie beine gewesen waren und
außerdem bis zu vier meter lang gewesen
sein sollen in dieselbe richtung geht
jetzt das ergebnis der aktuellen studie
demnach könnte es sich bei nässe mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit um einen
monster handeln dazu gäbe es gibt ein
sehr großes vorkommen anna dna unseren
daten gäben keinen aufschluss über ihre
größe aber angesichts der bloßen menge
des materials können wir nicht
ausschließen dass riesige alle im loch
lässt sind diese könnten also deutlich
größer sein als gewöhnliche alle dazu
heißt es in der studie
einer dieser größe wäre zwar außerhalb
der normalen größen spanne aber es
scheint nicht unmöglich dass ich ein
lebewesen zu einer so ungewöhnlich
größe entwickelt haben könnte eine
population von riesen ahlen könnte nach
ansicht der fachleute durch eine
mutation und die isolation im loch ness
entstanden sein
das forschungsteam erzählte durch den
detaillierten dna-analyse weitere
spannende ergebnisse denn es wurde
natürlich auch die dna anderer lebewesen
aufgespürt und zwar von 22 vogelarten
drei amphibien l fischarten und 19
spezies von säugetieren in dem
schottischen süßwassersee konnten
dagegen keine spuren von grönland einen
stören oder riesen welsen nachgewiesen
werden auch hinweise auf ein dinosaurier
ähnliches die tiere wurden nicht
aufgespürt somit kann auch diejenigen
theorie nach der ein preziosa überlebt
haben soll nicht belegt werden im
gegenteil denn nicht mal im
entferntesten sony dämme wurden
irgendwelche hinweise auf uhrzeit
kreaturen entdeckt so und wenn er jetzt
die videos früher und ohne werbung
bekommen wollt dann klickt hier drauf
dann geht's zu unserer intelligenz
community und mit monstern geht es
darunter weiter peilsender zeigt etwas
riesengroßes lauert in der tiefsee
draufklicken anschauen und neugier zone
abonnieren sehr sehr guter kanal bis
dann bleibt dran